amanda is with us in washington DC hey
Amanda how are you good how are you
doing better than I deserve how can I
help well first thank you for taking my
call
my husband and I are at a little bit of
a crossroads right now and we just I
guess just to assure that we're doing
the right thing we were seeking your
opinion we we built our dream home in
the Shenandoah Valley in 2014 and
thought this would just be the home that
we'd live out the rest of our days in
with our boys however the markets come
back and we have since building taking
your FPU class and we've been on baby
step two for about two years and we have
the opportunity right now to sell our
home for a pretty substantial profit
however because the market is good we
would probably be renting for the next
couple years until the market was less
desirable we wanted to get your opinion
on using our home as a means to pay off
baby step two and just kind of move on
with our lives
it would be my last choice unless you
hate your house if you hate your house
aren't going to move anyway then we
would use the money but selling your
home is one of the last things I do
sometimes there's situations where you
need to how much debt do you have not
counting your house we've probably got
about 50 thousand between student loans
and we had a pretty devastating car
experience last year so we had to
purchase a new vehicle so it set us back
quite a bit I'm sorry how do you how are
you forced to purchase a new vehicle we
had about $20,000 well it wasn't a new
vehicle it was new to us so we had we
had to take out a loan because we spent
most of our emergency fund trying to fix
the one that ended up needing replaced
in the end okay and so how much did you
how much card that do you have we have
about 14,000 in car debt okay
so instead of buying a hoopty you bought
a $14,000
yeah we were really afraid to get into
car issues again I'm terrified actually
to get into more car issues so we bought
something a little bit yeah too
expensive
yeah yeah if you keep doing that kind of
stuff you can't sell your house enough
times to get out of debt okay the reason
we are considering and selling is long
term we don't wish to stay here we're
hoping to lose your room home it was it
was before we realized what we had done
it was everything else climate our house
payments $2,100 a month then what is
your household take-home pay my husband
brings home 120 I'm a stay-at-home
homeschool mom so you're at 25% or less
so what is it that you've done it's it's
a very expensive house that we
custom-built we'd like to downsize and
be a little bit more reasonable with the
space that we have we feel like we're
kind of spinning our wheels with trying
to pay our debt down and I think that we
could we both think that we could have a
smaller home with less of a payment and
be just as happy this is the same lady
who just bought a $14,000 car cars or
other one broke down I mean we put
$15,000 into the other vehicles and the
gas tank ended up failing as you do
whatever you want to do huh it's gonna
be okay I would stay in your home and I
would buckle down my dadgum lifestyle
and clean up $50,000 worth of debt you
should be out of debt in under eight
around 18 months 20 12 to 18 months you
make $120,000 a year your household
income your house payment is less than
1/4 of your take-home pay
if you want to move move I don't care it
doesn't matter to me but III think that
you guys Vasiliy back and forth on what
is a crisis and what's important and if
you don't stop doing that
you can be broke your whole life because
you can justify all you want but that
car decision was a bad decision it was
stupid and and if you keep doing that
kind of stuff you can't sell your house
enough times to get out of it so and now
you're going to move to a smaller house
when this one actually seems okay in
terms of the pricing or the monthly on
it again if you don't like the house you
decide it's more bigger than you want I
don't want a big house I don't like the
upkeep I don't like whatever then that's
fine move for that reason but I don't
think you need to move to get out of
debt I think you need to get clear
boundaries on your life that we're not
borrowing money anymore and cut your
lifestyle and get on a tight budget and
then pay off your debt that's how you
get out of debt but if you want to move
I don't care move